well every day thousands of people
continue to get the covet 19 vaccine we
have been getting questions
about making appointments on the health
district's website joe muller joins us
live
at the cashman center the largest
vaccination site right here in clark
county joe
yeah well cashman center here opened on
friday last week county and health
district officials said crews were
working around the clock to fix a number
of issues
on their website people were having
issues booking appointments because no
times
were available well now on the health
district's website you can only book
seven days out last week many were
complaining that appointments were not
available until next
month this is the window that pops up
according to the health district this is
an automated message you are encouraged
to keep checking back as dates continue
to be added
an official says the amount of
appointments also depends on the weekly
amount of vaccines that are brought in
locally
now those in the education bracket will
be able to make an appointment
the website states to check back after
today
today we also caught up with people
arriving to get the vaccine they said it
wasn't the easiest thing to make an
appointment but they are happy they got
in
having issues too i just kept trying
kept trying and kept trying and finally
got
an appointment time so i must have tried
eight nine ten times
and that is the key to keep trying other
locations by the southern nevada health
district our bonanza high school and the
health district office you can make
appointments for those online as well
now the encore at wind convention center
is now a home to
umc's newest vaccination site that
location started operating today you
must have an appointment for the health
district locations
and umc as well no there are no walk-ups
now back out
here live after you get your first
appointment to get the vaccine you must
make a follow-up appointment uh two
weeks later uh
the website for the health district is
gonna start allowing people to make
those appointments starting january
25th reporting live in las vegas joe
muller 8 news now